à l'ombre des centaines d'admirateurs et
d'admiratrices de la princesse diana se
sont précipités chez christie's pour
admirer les 79 euros prochainement mise
en enchères à new york au profit
d'oeuvres caritatives des enchères qui
pourrait rapporter jusqu'à 50 millions
de francs la vente des sols catalogue a
déjà rapporté plus de 5 millions de
francs à londres pour france 2 et tiéné
comment tu te fais en trois actes à
l'acte premier la princesse vient
officiellement donné le coup d'envoi de
ce qui s'annonce comme la plus
médiatisée des ventes aux enchères de
cette fin de siècle
cette vente est merveilleuse et j'en
suis très fier à l'acte de l'est sujet
se précipitent par centaines pour
observer avec émerveillement les 79 robe
que diane sacrifie au profit d'oeuvres
caritatives
d'une certaine manière c'est un peu du
patrimoine national qui s'éparpillent
chaque robe pour les anglaises est elle
une histoire c'est trop bois représente
la fin d'une époque c'est celle qu'elle
portait le soir où le prince charles a
fait ce terrible aveu à la télé qu'elle
ait pu sortir avec cette robe
éblouissante
alors qu'à la télévision son mari avoué
des infidélités c'était tout simplement
grandiose
robes des jours heureux pour un bal
australien robe de gala pour soirée
versaillaise robe officielle pour dîner
élyséen
toutes ces robes symbole d'une autre vie
que ces dames content avec un soupir
nostalgie je pense que c'est un moyen
pour tirer un trait sur le passé avoir
possédé toutes ces robes tout c'est
qu'elle a eue et d'un autre côté avoir
tout perdu
surtout l'homme qu'elle aimait à l'acte
iii fin juin à new york chaque robe sera
mise à prix 25 mille francs on y attend
des enchères record plus de 50 millions
de francs
de nos jours les histoires de princesses
sont parfois belles parfois triste mais
elles sont bien souvent hors de prix